so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dobasiolo whatever you want to call me i
am here with my co-host marty o'neal
what's up what's up happy birthday marty
first off real quick it's marty's
birthday thank you sir you turned
twilight zone age today
36. hi um guys today i'm hyped we talked
about this for a couple weeks uh we we
mentioned it for for a while now
i'm excited guys today's guest is namesh
patel you guys ready for stand up can we
i'm ready man i i like i told you before
we started
i'm a fan something i saw a lot of you
guys react oh hell yeah people are hyped
bro i'm hyped what the [ __ ]
youtube hates us like i tried to cuss in
the first 10 seconds but yeah it's
already gone it's all good man thank you
for having me thanks for coming dude and
uh on time as hell which is awesome
punctual to the max where you from
jersey oh okay this was from new york oh
yeah i mean i was born and raised in
jersey but i went to school at nyu so
i've been in new york since uh
04 basically do you live now yeah i live
in brooklyn oh okay i went to new york
for the first time last month
first time ever ever
i don't
meet people like i'm like how is that
drug dealer my whole life oh really i
don't travel anywhere that's my second
time leaving anywhere get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah i don't go anywhere that's
why you i guess you don't care
i mean like i was from a small town so
if i'm just selling packs and stuff if
i'm gone that's a new connect i lost
that guy he he buys from someone else
got it going nowhere dude that makes
sense yeah but recently i've been
traveling uh-huh yeah you've been
getting around here i went to vegas
earlier i'm surprised that was the
second place you've been no i've been to
vegas all the time oh it's drive uh-huh
did you did you drive to new york
no we flew i hated it
i hated it new york is dope
is great new york is a [ __ ] compare real
quick you're from new york so uh-huh how
is la compared i already knew what you
said
[Laughter]
man on the drive here i'm like man i
hate los angeles it's just so
everything's just so spread out you know
like i love just lose so much time and
[ __ ] ubers and [ __ ] i'm like
i can't stand it and granted you spend a
lot of time in like the subway in new
york and [ __ ] but it doesn't feel like
the same it's the weird transients in in
l.a where i'm just like
i hate him sitting in traffic for no
[ __ ] reason there's never an
explanation i know it's like
there's never an explanation it's a
cliche thing to hate on la for but it's
the truth that's why it's a thing that
everyone says like it's but it's also
like very isolating in los angeles it
feels and that might just be a function
of fact i don't have any i have like
three friends here but it's also just
like i don't know what anyone's doing
everyone's like seems so separate and
everyone's doing something but
everyone's doing nothing at the same
time that's what it feels like a great
way to put that [ __ ] you know yeah when
i went to new york i'm like yo
everyone's got something to do here yeah
[ __ ] out of my way sorry yeah yeah but
in new york is the same like the vibe is
the same when it comes to like the
people like everyone's trying in motion
but no one's really going anywhere in
l.a it just feels different for some
reason i don't know what it is maybe
it's smoking weed yeah that's what it's
in my own head where i'm just like
what what is this place i still don't
know how awesome has it been having
legal weed though it's been fantastic
but again like uh uh weed to me has
never been inaccessible you know it's
always
just [ __ ] order people just come to
your house and drop that [ __ ] off that's
like a half-baked [ __ ] yeah it's true oh
dude i didn't know that
in new york you could just order that
[ __ ] come to your house i got a service
now they come within an hour they're at
my crib so it's like like it's even more
convenient than here first oh for sure
you know i've got to walk into some
place and give them my id or anything
like that it's just there you go here's
a week like okay cool and if i were
smoking like huge volumes it might make
a difference like go into some place or
buy like ounces from i don't know i
don't know what prices are i just i'm
pretty agnostic to price i'm just i
don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not smoking that much where it
really matters to me so you're like the
guys smoking a couple bowls here and
there yeah just like once in a while or
like if i gotta do some writing or
whatever i'm like okay if i if i've
stuck on some idea i'm like okay let me
smoke a little find it it helps oh for
sure oh wow i'm the opposite it's
definitely a
a creative tool for sure what's your
normal order pre-rolls flower dabs
edibles pre-rolls for sure uh or like
flowers
small ones
you don't smoke too much oh my god what
the [ __ ] is this
that's the joints this is literally i'm
worried about he's tall as [ __ ] and
that's the size one
holy [ __ ]
jesus christ bro yeah i'm gonna have one
hit of this man
oh yeah all right fine but i got more
[ __ ] for you
i'll be ahead of this and then i will be
catatonic for sure dude is this a does
it do you find that it matters if it's
sativa or indica or anything like that i
only smoke heavy heavy oh geez indicas
but this i switch it up because not
everybody can [ __ ] deal with that
this is so delicious from a homies 22
red it's like a cross of purple and like
a cookie it looks like so okay
from system over down that's his weed
shot that's this week oh okay great
[ __ ] weed i gotta be honest is it
good it's really good okay cool i'll
have to try yeah um okay so the
difference is no one's doing [ __ ] here
but everyone's doing something yeah yeah
i mean i was at a restaurant last night
at like 10 30 at night and it's packed
and i'm like
what all these people talking about
what are you doing yeah doing here yeah
what do you got you [ __ ] patek
philippe on it seems like making all
these wild hand gestures i'm like this
is it feels like such a cliche l.a kind
of place yeah and i'm sitting there as
like like also doing the cliche la thing
is being by myself with my hoodie on
looking at people like okay you know i
wonder if people look at me like [ __ ]
this dude in shorts for sure at this
fancy sports and hoodies yeah
i [ __ ] feel you
that's you have a ladder right next to
you
also
i i'm not from i'm from buffalo so it's
like i'm barely
no lighting from new york
uh but i still have an intense like i
have a burning thing inside me if i feel
like i'm in somebody's way or if
somebody's in my way if i'm walking or
driving or just anything in life i feel
like that's a new york thing like i
always feel like i got to get the [ __ ]
out of the way and i want people to get
the [ __ ] out of my way i don't know man
cause when i went over there
i gotta be honest dude i've only seen
[ __ ] movies forrest gump with
lieutenant dan that's what i know about
new york and seinfeld i know nothing
else you know
i thought everybody's gonna be hella
mean i meant no rude people bro
everybody was nice and there was more
weed smoking than here that's what
shocked me there was people walking on
the street smoking joints way more than
la oh yeah yeah la i mean it feels like
in new york it's like brand new to the
culture so everyone's just like [ __ ] it
where are you oh is that why because
there's there's weed vans on the corner
there now
giving a [ __ ]
about uh weed and [ __ ] it's kind of cool
to see
it's [ __ ] cool man because i know
he's like do i get [ __ ] arrested
yeah like that to me it being i used to
it wasn't so [ __ ] sleek with the
delivery when i was getting weed i had
to go on a mission every time to get
that buffalo it's like
a different buffalo yeah oh it wasn't
all i'm a bendy of the butcher
really you wanna know funny story
uh so i used to run the show with uh my
friend michael che of weekend update snl
thing oh yeah and this guy named mike
denny
mike denny
comic from new york from boston but
lived in new york
always wanted to do music
once broken comedy that was the name of
the show ended uh we
none of us knew where the [ __ ] he had
gone uh and he had a falling out with
myself and che and all that kind of [ __ ]
and i had nothing to love her to do but
you know he hates my guts for whatever
reason
but
now a producer with benny of the butcher
oh no [ __ ] wedding shotgun epm danny
look up look up his [ __ ] if you go on
spotify and you look up to the latest uh
west side gun album he's got like eight
tracks on that [ __ ] album yeah he's
no [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so it's hilarious
that you've just played it yeah marty's
just did the music out of buffalo with
those fools yeah yeah so if you text
them no [ __ ] tell them
that epm denny's is
a funny dude
is that what kind of music you're
generally into like what is your top
music
uh i'm i'm all over the place you know i
the one thing i
regret if i can say that word correctly
is uh that my
music year in knowledge isn't as
in depth and extensive as i would like
it to be because i know people who are
[ __ ] music heads and i'm just
yeah i'm just like man i wish i wish i
had like an ounce of the knowledge you
got because really that's all i want is
just like
so i'm just starting like re getting
into the beatles oh good [ __ ] you know
just like like i just
put their playlist um
on spotify it's called this is you know
this is the beatles i'm just like going
through all that [ __ ]
uh
trying to watch all the documentaries i
can
george harrison's uh all things must
pass is like probably like my favorite
album at the moment but like so i'm
listening to everything like hip hop is
what i grew up listening to uh but now
my you know i'm just trying to expand my
ear and try to listen as much as i can
good [ __ ] beatles one of my favorite uh
my favorite albums is a rubber soul by
the beatles is an old [ __ ] i don't
know see
i've been since i was i got a wire
memory so i remember albums and people
and yeah and all that [ __ ] so but i have
homies that make me feel stupid bro how
do you know the [ __ ] producer from
1971
underground beautiful tree yeah it's
like i don't know anything i don't know
that [ __ ] i know phil spector did this
with george harrison and he killed a
[ __ ] after [ __ ] i know that
i don't know what he did yeah i don't
know anything like that you know it's
just like so like that uh uh
is like where i'm where i'm at musically
right now for a long time i was just
listening to travis scott non-stop i
just constantly it's like
jay i was talking the other day we were
in a car together and he just go i was
like put on some travis scott and
he's travis has some goofy ass lyric
and he's like he's not really a lyricist
he's more like a vibest you know it's
just like that i don't know you know
he's a survivors that's what chase said
i'm like that's exactly right you just
this is a weird vibe
yeah and that for whatever i guess
when astroworld came out i think my
where i was at in life intersected with
some of the lyrics in that uh uh on that
album was like called okay i'm [ __ ]
with this and then we went to the show
how was it astroworld
barclay center
like this [ __ ] puts on you
understand why people die at his shows
he literally killed his motherfucker's a
monster but also about that houston [ __ ]
i was in houston in april this year and
i made a travis scott joke people i got
applause break for it and not to my own
horn only to say that people came up to
me afterwards and we're like yo we were
at that show and that [ __ ] that happened
was happening like 20 feet away from us
and we had no [ __ ] idea
so i'm not trying to absolve travis or
drake of any other responsibility
because i do think they hold some but
it's like
in that moment you might have not known
what the [ __ ] was going on if people who
were there and they didn't know twenty
feet away that people was that guy
paying attention to this yeah
and again it's a [ __ ]
tragic situation in a tense situation i
don't know but i do know that people in
houston told me like yo we were at that
show and we had no idea what was going
on it was happening like 20 feet away
from us ugh so yeah all that to say
travis
sorry for the families out there but
that album was hard yeah [ __ ] was great
my friend just i just actually i popped
up my instagram reels uh
uh clip of kevin durant at the travis
scott show in london going [ __ ] crazy
towering yeah yeah everyone that was
really that was really the funniest
shade like a foot taller than the next
person next to him but he's now just
going crazy i'm like that's my guy yeah
kevin durant's harder
to say devil's hard man you don't ever
get in trouble he's just chilling yeah
i respect that i [ __ ] with that he's
like a peyton manning
[Music]
talk to me what happened you know peyton
manning putting his balls on trainer's
faces
i'm telling you the truth
you know about this
allegedly like a tea bag
physical uh therapist and i think in his
college days or was like right before he
went to the nfl it was like or maybe
even while he was at the colts like put
his balls on
like a physical therapist's face were
they laying on the ground
the first thing i thought was he ain't
that tall
no idea look that's all i know yeah look
if i'm wrong i'm sorry denver
the colts fan first cancelable bag and
i've ever heard
normally his teabag is pretty enjoyable
normally it's it's not
it's not what is it what would you say
it's willing yeah yeah i'm never going
to go to the ball you're getting close
you got to be in quite the position to
be like no you got to be [ __ ] bench
pressing you're fixing a car
you can't surprise teabag somebody
unless you're in a very specific
situation
i'd like to know how to lay down close
your eyes surprise tea bag is a great
title
you might feel a weird smell
surprise there you go write that down
oh can i open this joe crack that [ __ ]
up
um i don't usually drink during the day
while smoking weed but when i do
thank you for sponsoring the podcast
ah
i'll remember to not call my daughter
[ __ ] i started i'm kidding i'm kidding i
don't have a daughter
that's a micro scene joke he goes uh he
says you know there's a
like cigar aficionado magazine there
should be a cigarette fiction auto
magazine where it's like
yeah this uh marlborough red goes really
well with uh your daughter not returning
your phone calls
it's just a miller light joke
that's a shout out mike racine [ __ ] with
that so new jersey i uh so on this show
i do my homework but i don't like to do
all my [ __ ] homework because i want
to learn right you know what i'm saying
so you're raised in new jersey went to
new york i saw that you
and your family ran a store my dad had a
liquor store uh in east orange new
jersey
what the [ __ ] does that mean stop tell
me what's going on why am i left it's
not a good neighbor orange new jersey is
a lot different than orange crunch
county
yes it's almost the exact opposite so is
it like a buffalo yeah where you were
born man i've driven through east orange
before yeah and i remember my boys in
the backseat looking out like
that [ __ ] are getting your
homies over here
it's on up and up maybe i don't know but
it wasn't good when my dad was there but
it was like the street that the store
was on was like decent and uh i think we
he had it until probably i won't say oh
four or five or something like that but
yeah it was uh uh where like how i
understood the
liquor store business a little bit here
and there and like just what it meant to
uh grow up surrounded by that you know
how old how old were you when this
started
uh
well we lived in the burbs so i don't
want to
misconstrue it as like we were in the
hood and all that kind of bad straw was
in the hood but i was not uh i don't
know it was as long as i can remember
this oh this is how you just grew up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah was it like
always some crazy [ __ ] going on that's
my next question no i mean it might if
if there was my dad never let on uh that
it was constantly crazy i i don't you
know that you can paint a bad
neighborhood as a bad neighborhood but
that doesn't mean it's constantly bad
and it's like constantly getting robbed
anything like that like some stores were
kind of
almost like a safe space was like
everyone needs that [ __ ] you know you
have to be a pretty bad way to knock it
off i'm sure i'm sure i remember my dad
saying people tried to steal all the
time like kids would come in and try to
like jack chips and all that [ __ ] but
that's typical or you just have fools
bumping into each other in the store
that's the other thing yeah no i mean my
dad never let on that that kind of [ __ ]
was going on and it didn't i think the
store was almost like neutral ground of
that kind of [ __ ] bass
exactly
yeah every once the md4040 you know it
was like that kind of damn i would love
the play
it was yeah it was it was that kind of
spot you know uh swisher's a mad dog it
was it switched as a mad dog that's like
an order someone would give my back here
you go 790 you know whatever the [ __ ]
were you like pulling papers and
blessings no no no my dad did not let me
work at the store at all oh no no no i
mean i went to the store a few times uh
not a few a good number of times but
like only for the weekend because i'm
like my mom could go hang out there and
see my dad because my dad was just
constantly working so they you know
spend some time together and or like uh
my cousin lived
you know a block or two blocks away from
the store so whenever i went to my
cousin's place we could go hang out it
would be like a walk down the street to
go to my desk as hell but uh uh beyond
that no i was not like allowed to work
there but not from a because it was a
bad neighborhood but b also because for
whatever reason my parents had this like
weird mentality that if i
uh that i shouldn't work i got to just
stay focused on school anything like
that damn that's tight which is cool but
in hindsight you know i'm like well had
i learned to work then i would have
learned the value of money and how hard
it is to
make money and i wouldn't just be
buying
goofy ass [ __ ] all the time you know
it's just going crazy like balling out
with [ __ ] when i don't have it you know
but you know to each their own that
turned out fine
yo that's hard though man i would that's
such a cool up i think i from from
my perspective it's like the opposite
it's like yo you're broke as [ __ ] that
was it yeah it's it i mean you know
there was
it has its merits uh
you know hey my dad wasn't home all the
time so that was always tough but it was
also like
his approach to life and living would as
when i look at it now it makes a lot
more sense you know like the man has
been shot at you know so [ __ ] so it's
like uh and
and he's also worked since he was 17
doing the same thing constantly you know
so
he's like i talked to him now i'm like
retire he's like no i love to work i'm
like that's like that's like you've been
ingrained that's a capitalism man
you know
you know
but uh the idea of life is short you
never know what's gonna happen to you i
kind of live like that a little bit even
though i don't necessarily want to but
like i kind of do
and that comes from i'm sure some kind
of subconscious
uh uh
reading of my dad behaving that way as
well i think he'd behave the same way
you know and i'm sure some
small part of it was because
bang bang you know like you get shot at
pushing perspective from time to time
[ __ ] yeah
so yeah uh it's interesting better
growth
because they're pushing you so much into
school where they bummed out that you
got into comedy
well i mean i don't think they were
bummed out uh i think they were
concerned and confused because like they
don't know what it is do they find you
funny yeah yeah yeah yeah
you ain't funny
wow that's got to be the worst there's a
comic when your parents are like you're
not even [ __ ]
they they are very supportive my dad and
my mom they come to every they come
tonight they watch everything everything
that goes up on youtube or whatever
they'll make sure to see it but
uh they weren't disappointed they were
like
fearful because it's like such an
unknown path and no one really knows
what it is especially two immigrants
from india who are like he's going to be
a doctor or finance person or get a
master's degree in something yeah so
when i started you know i wasn't working
that was then then the concern became
how you gonna pay the bills like we
can't can't live at home forever you
know and then once i got a job i was
like okay
do you want to advance in this job and
then once i advance in comedy like okay
does this pay as well as the other thing
you were doing and then when like maybe
like five days ago they became okay with
comedy
you know what i mean but it was very
recent like in the last year and a half
like that became like uh okay he's doing
[ __ ] like he's on the road he's making
money like things are good but again
it's always
around the corner i mean i get shot at
or whatever knock on wood but uh
something could happen where that could
go away like touring could go away
pandemic yeah exactly
like luckily you know
i wasn't touring like crazy i wasn't
touring at all before pandemic happened
and then
lo and behold pandemic happened i was
able to put all my stuff out there and
and kind of build a fan base and then
expand upon that you were just going
heavy at the comedy cellar and all the
places in new york exactly uh before
pandemic you know i had a a job i was
working as a producer at a tv show um
and i was just doing stand-up it was
cool but it wasn't like the best gig and
it wasn't like a creative outlet in any
way it was producing is very different
than writing
uh uh you gotta like put stuff together
and like
goofy [ __ ] it's a very different is it
there's a tv show it was uh full frontal
it was a man the beat
full frontal with the most walk show on
television
but it was uh uh what's it called
uh a fun experience and sam and the team
that are fantastic and super funny uh
but
uh while it wasn't a creative outlet i
was just doing
that so i could pay bills and it was
like an interesting way to like it was a
different skill set but i was doing
stand-up at the time like at the seller
and all that pandemic happened i also
lost that job right like a month before
dynamic happened so i was like okay
now what now i gotta find another gig or
like get a writing job or something else
which is a lot easier said than done
yeah like impossible almost at least i
found it so but then pandemic happened
and no one was working and everything's
confused as to what the [ __ ] was going
on thank god for uh socialism and the
government gave me money unemployment
helped me pay rent and all that and put
my stuff up on youtube and it started
generating a little bit of revenue like
oh
interesting okay this could be something
start putting more clips up than that
summer of 2020.
like one of my clips went like crazy
viral
and it was like an election clip and so
like i'm
there was like
they were paying a lot of money for ads
uh
during that because it was an election
year and specifically on political
content and so like i made like a chunk
of money i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm famous and rich on youtube now
let's get another apartment i mean get a
two-bedroom apartment set a one-bedroom
apartment and we like made this huge
jump and then after like two months that
went back down to like
a tenth of what it was i'm like [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] uh i gotta keep going and just keep
putting stuff up and then uh
got on tick tock in november of 2020
after like my wife had told me first i
didn't listen my boy told me so him
saying he was like you should get on
then i listened and i got on it and then
like i got a writing job at lily sing
i feel like i'm doing last call on kanye
[ __ ] right now
[Laughter]
and uh uh what's it called um
[Music]
november 2020 i got a writing job with
lily singh and i was my [ __ ] was on
youtube
so i wasn't really paying attention tic
tac i wasn't gonna pay attention to tic
toc and then
uh
uh like march april
my writing job but lily ended but at the
same time my tick tock started taking
off like crazy
and i had a bunch of dates lined i had
date lined up in houston and i was like
let's see if we can use tick tock to
sell tickets
lo and behold we went from like a one
night seventy person show to like a two
night
four shows with 200 people each damn so
i went from like 70 to 800 because of
tick tock and i was like oh this is real
let me or is it real let me try in
dallas added a dallas off night they
gave it to us sold out added austin off
night sold out added two more austin
sold out you know san antonio sold out i
was like oh [ __ ] we got a [ __ ] we got
a game going and uh then it was then it
was off to the races you know my uh
my manager helped you know put me in
front of an agent tj and tj was like yo
i'm [ __ ] with it and then and tj is
also shows his ancient so he andrew
schulze's agent so he knows the game
about like self-made so to speak
self-produced people
and that's been it you know last year
and a half it's just been like
my manager reg tj my agent and me just
putting dates together like all right
and then my social media team of crowds
are being like yo we gotta [ __ ] we
gotta sell this out we gotta sell this i
keep going keep going and that's it
it sounds very simple and it feels very
simple like as i'm talking about it but
it's like the day-to-day is
a lot yeah that's literally
you you made yourself and you make your
whole living off of
hey [ __ ] you know like to see
it yeah put it out there yeah that's
what we do yeah so to hear that it's it
literally that's exactly how it happens
like i don't know what the [ __ ] i just
tried yeah i kept going just try and
keep going and throwing [ __ ] at a wall
at some point you got to make sure that
your arm is in good motion when you're
throwing [ __ ] at the wall you know your
form's got to be right and the [ __ ] you
got to be throwing it's got to be sticky
otherwise it's not going to stick you
know
you know what i mean
but with all that in order you got to
keep throwing [ __ ] at the wall you know
the wall's not going to change you got
to change your [ __ ] up and just catch us
to change your [ __ ] is that man you
mainly post clubs it's awesome it's just
stand up it's all stan you know i've
been fortunate that uh i've been doing
comedy for 13 years now but oh wow all
together yeah yeah but in like uh at the
seller i got passed in 2016 but i don't
know when they started recording clips
and stuff but the comedy cell in new
york like
i'll make sure to get as many clips as i
could and then i was just lucky i had
this huge backlog of all stand up i
didn't give i wasn't going to be doing
it ever again
a lot of being just random crowd
interactions a lot of it being material
that i don't care about anymore
and uh you know start chopping all this
[ __ ] up and just putting it out putting
it out putting it out and uh
here we are if you had to describe your
style of comedy or the topics you'd like
to hit on how would you describe it
uh well the older stuff is pretty social
uh
uh
not really political i have like some
political stuff but nothing too crap i
mean
the 20 thing i think i recorded in 2019
was pretty political
uh
uh because it was like election almost
election time and it was like bernie and
trump all [ __ ]
and then uh
thank you china which is my last special
came out youtube
maybe one political note like joke but
mostly social observations about like
uh how we all started drinking in
america how everyone feels kind of lost
in this country and then trying to make
that as personal as possible and then
this current hour that i'm on tour with
right now is
99 personal it's just about
[ __ ] i'm going through right now it's
just like very deeply personal
and jokey you know i got a lot of jokes
you know i like jokes so nice um quick
question
what was the first time no what was it
when was the first time you ever did
stand-up august 19th 2009. [ __ ] knew
you're gonna know that i i knew it so
you know the date don't you
good [ __ ] were you [ __ ] scared on the
way up
oh there's never i've never had stage
fright in that sense of what cause
people are gonna look at me it was more
like i was scared like this material
gonna work that's that's sorry that's
what i meant for sure for sure yeah
stage fright i mean once you don't give
a [ __ ] about people i can be in front of
a thousand people or six right it don't
matter don't give a [ __ ] i just water i
was just curious if the material would
work or not and uh it did so it was fine
did you find yourself just doing
because uh
this is something i've always
had an interest in do you find yourself
before you started
just hoping that you could tell some
[ __ ] jokes
and just kept growing from there kind of
like what you're doing on social media
like i just tried and i really had
zero expectations beyond me thinking
this is going to be so easy
you know like i i if i were to have any
emotion then it was pure arrogance but
also
the kind of arrogance that comes from
pure ignorance like i had no idea what i
was getting into i was just like oh i
could get on stage and talk [ __ ]
and uh
how hard could it be
pretty hard
you know like just the
getting on stage and all that is is
relatively easy when it comes to like uh
actually doing it for real like anyone
get on stage but to like make something
of it and not even just like
become quote unquote successful in it
but actually like
have a set and write actual jokes that
are coherent cohesive and like have
stage presence and all that that is like
you don't even think about that when
you're starting at least i didn't think
about it when i started it was just like
natural
you know and then you got to be a
performer it's like being a musician
almost there's all these like
intangibles you don't realize till you
start doing it yeah yeah so there's so
much and like that goes into it you're
not even aware of it until you're
13 years in even you know like and still
even still you know like you don't stay
i'm i'm not at least hyper analytical
immediately it'll take me a second to
become to start analyzing something and
uh uh
i never analyzed stand up before i
started it was just like all right let's
just get on that's cool which is good
uh in that i wasn't a heavy student of
it so everything i've learned has just
been on the fly
sometimes it's easier we're not all
obsessed with it and like you you're not
all [ __ ] eight mile about it yeah all
these years your life's depending on it
you just go out there it's fun it works
that's beautiful you're never gonna go
home and get hired yeah i hope you guys
like this show yeah i like that it's
really good
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about the sponsor of this episode and
that would be miller lite so right now
if you're watching this episode and you
want a mirror light but you don't want
to go to the store right now go to
millerlight.com forward slash yola and
that's going to take you to a landing
page on any place that delivers beer to
you but if you're in the mood to go
somewhere go to the store grab middle
lights anywhere they sell beer miller
lite is the light beer for people that
actually like the taste of beer
miller lite is light for a reason it's
under 100 calories it's 96 calories it's
less than a soda 3.2 grams of carbs for
all the people out there watching their
diet and that's per can all right that's
under 100 calories per can i just moved
into a new spot i'm ready for football
so i know i have to keep time off
football but guys it's almost september
it's almost here this is a newest spot i
can't wait to have people over we have
miller lives we have drinks we're gonna
be hanging out eating chips american
stuff but always guys don't drink and
drive celebrate responsibly all right
milwaukee brewing company milwaukee
wisconsin and on that note remember go
to millerlight.com forward slash ola and
go to a landing page i'll show you
anybody and everywhere that will bring
you beer so you don't have to drive but
if you're not already drinking guys go
to the store grab a 12-pack grab
whatever you want just remember miller
light dope as usual podcast thank you
question you live in the suburbs your
parents got the store you said you grew
up like i'm not in the hood what kind of
kid i have a feeling what kind of kid
were you in high school man i was an
arrogant [ __ ]
i would chip on my shoulder yeah honest
answer uh
but i didn't see myself as arrogant when
i was then in that moment i didn't see
myself as arrogant what i saw myself is
was
confident and uh aspirational and i was
dressing and acting the part
of being successful without actually
being successful you know i was like
smart in school
you know a good student yeah great
grades you know and from not not and not
from like
trying really hard i just had it at the
time you know like if i were to be a
student now i think i would be a
terrible student um and again like again
if we're gonna list regrets it's like
music and then
not being able to learn and uh as much
as i'd like uh but at the time i was
like i could pick anything up and so
uh i had that kind of chip on my
shoulder as a kid
uh and plus my dad's store was doing
okay like we weren't rich by any means
but
you know that's like clips lines like
half a million and 20 is a billion
dollars from where i'm from you know
like there's like it's kind of like that
where it's like
even he didn't have a half million
dollars it's just we just it just felt
like we were doing good so that feeds
into you you know i'm like i got polos
and lacoste and [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that kind of [ __ ]
uh
again completely unearned confidence
yeah uh except for the fact that i was
doing well in school you know and i was
tall
one yeah well i was like six feet six
one on a good day so look to all this
[ __ ] thank you
thank you [ __ ] see me go damn i
thought you were tall that's why we
booked you actually it was the height
yeah we were like yo we need some light
bulbs changed after [ __ ] people
hit like on the in the when i do like
meet and greets and stuff people like
you're a lot taller in person like what
the hell how would i come off as short
on the [ __ ] camera i guess i do
uh but yeah
so like i had that kind of confidence
it's okay to feel good about yourself
though most kids just don't i feel like
yeah that's [ __ ] amazing i think it's
awesome yeah if you're not a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] about it no
i'm sure i was like i was like
i get what you're saying like i wish i
could have slapped myself back then a
little bit yeah yeah be humble man
i mean i was definitely uh and i think a
lot of that
for better for worse made me
funny but my funny if i look back at it
was like usually mean or like at the
expense of somebody but like not like
bullying but like i could i could cut
you down pretty fast like make snide
remarks and all that kind of [ __ ] uh and
not all the time i wasn't like a bully
by any means i don't want to portray
myself as that at least i don't think i
was uh but
i think that comedy is a function of
that arrogance were you playing sports
too no no
no athletic
bones in my body i mean i thought i was
okay at basketball but then you mean
people are good about it yeah yeah you
crossed yeah yeah once you get crossed
over okay yeah oh my who the [ __ ] am i
yeah you play like against like a d3
like backup player and you're like yeah
yeah my knees broke
did you play d3 yeah yeah yeah barney's
good at
play someone who's like even you if
you're playing like a d1 person or like
like [ __ ] oh please yeah it's [ __ ]
over for you you know it's like the same
thing like the difference is so i know i
even played my high school team by any
means so it wasn't i'm not good at all i
just enjoy talking [ __ ] and i talk [ __ ]
better than most people yeah
yeah yeah this honest answer [ __ ] is
exactly
the way i felt like i hope i wasn't a
piece of [ __ ] but you guys started it
like i've made i feel bad i've made a
few people cry in class but i didn't
[ __ ] start it [ __ ]
yeah do you i see your mom don't talk
[ __ ] about your mom after school and i
can talk [ __ ]
like i will [ __ ] i'm i feel bad i was
a nice kid though yeah i thought i tried
man i tried i [ __ ] tried too man you
know i look and try to i had to ask dude
um so when you go into college
that's when you're that's when you're
starting to think
comedy no because you're 23 as you said
well when i stopped when i ended college
yes oh that's when you stop when i when
i started college i was gung-ho about
being a doctor i wanted to be a doctor
that was like you know it's a cliche but
it's like but also probably like
was brainwashing thinking i wanted to be
one uh but i did want to be one on the
surface at least
and then
uh
junior year i dropped pre-med
because i got like a c in organic
chemistry
and i was like i don't really [ __ ] this
was hard man i think i just quit like i
don't want to do this this is too hard
and my heart's not in it but you had two
years of going to school for so you can
like if i cut my [ __ ] you can help me
out right now i would be like that is
ectoplasm
i don't know what that is either
i've heard that word in school i have no
idea i know what a [ __ ] nucleus is
and that's about all that's right no but
that like i i just dropped it thinking
man i got i still have this finance
degree right like that's why i went to
cup like my major was finance
and all my electives were pre-med
classes but when i dropped it again i
wasn't thinking about the future
necessarily i was thinking about the
right now which is i hate this [ __ ] i
don't do it i'm doing it poorly maybe
i'm not as good as i thought i was maybe
i'm not as all these kids are [ __ ]
smart getting a's and [ __ ] i ain't [ __ ]
and then uh
same thing with a finance degree like
when i graduated like i thought i'd get
a job did not get a job all by all
meanwhile all my friends were like
going out to like be bankers and stuff
like investment bankers i'm like what
the [ __ ] am i doing and then like a year
i was at home living in jersey which is
like a very humbling time but that's
when i right after that i started comedy
and i started comedy with like the same
arrogance that i went to nyu with which
was
i got this you know it was like it's so
easy i bet the other comics really love
that yeah yeah of course
hey no that's [ __ ] awesome i love
that [ __ ] because it's just natural
you never have the fear of like
am i funny by [ __ ] i don't i really
don't care yeah i'm at this point
i was like just like that i was like it
it wasn't even
it was like i know i'm funny and i know
i'm smart at least i think i am at the
time uh
turns out i'm not
either one of those things as much as i
thought i was or think i am but uh at
the time
comedy running
i mean look look who's doing it
hey man you're honest
you went from pre-med to finance to tv
production to comedy
i don't think we've heard that well no
no i went i was the production was just
a like a comedy job it was i wasn't it
wasn't like
i've been doing stand-ups since 0-9 that
was like that comedy job that production
job was like six months
of
you know very long four months of a
career gotcha yeah um i saw you did you
said writing is your [ __ ] the creative
outlet that's what you like to do i saw
as i said a little bit of homework are
you writing an snl for a weekend update
yeah i did that for
a year a season
bro that's the only part of snl that's
even okay anymore i feel bad
i feel bad bro but those are those are
peers of mine and friends of mine and uh
uh che my closest friend head writer for
the show
it's very
hard to make
a 90-minute brand new thing every week
every week
at that level for 40 years for 40 years
you're going to see some misses yeah
there's going to be some drop offs yeah
dana carvey comes back i'm there kareem
didn't hit every shot you know
i feel you holby missed a lot too you
know he missed the most shots i had a
meme yesterday about like kobe has like
the most misses ever or something she
had a true statement yeah it might be
it's one of mine
[Applause]
the [ __ ] was a meme all right yeah
kobe's got the most misses
i don't know about that one even if it's
true even if it is true that's still
crazy still crushes it he's still the
greatest player ever played against that
was the point you know that he had of
course yeah so of course but i grew up
on uh snl as a kid because my mom used
to remember these two greatest hits on
tape
phil hardman chris farrell had all that
[ __ ] as a kid so i grew up on this and
until i started selling drugs and i'm
not home saturday night right that's
where i stopped watching the simpsons
football style
what a turn what i mean drugs took so
much it wasn't sad yeah no but they gave
so much to me
i have netflix now so it's okay man like
awesome circle background circle back i
don't know who's in ufc right now but i
will catch up catch up catch it up man
yeah yeah
so as far as movies go like lifetime
where would you say you lean is it the
is it the um
chris farley adam sandler genre
where where do you lean with like
all-time movies
oh man my list is so
wide and varied but also because i
haven't watched a lot of films oh you
have so my list of good movies is this
if you're asking my top 10 movies it's
probably like 10 of the 15 i've seen oh
[ __ ]
you know but that's
let me back up for a second i've
probably seen a lot i just don't
remember most of them yeah you know like
because they'd be just on wb they'd just
be on yeah you know oh okay this is
[ __ ] predator too like uh
but i'm asking about predator too i
don't know i've seen it daddy glover's
in it yeah yeah predator one i remember
they cut the jungle down with the
machine gun like that's a wild scene
yeah but that's just hard that's who i
am key points he remembers the he knows
that that's different
i have a [ __ ] crazy memory and i grew
up like uh the cable guy it's like my
mom just it was my babysitter that's
exactly what she was all smoking let me
hit this meth you watch this show and
i'll chill my [ __ ] yeah run it out bundy
control math and chill yeah [ __ ] netflix
sitter i imagine you could do math and
like sit still and like how fast your
brain is running it it must be it sucks
really it sucks dick i've done meth a
few times as a kid
as a kid
i'm from at the capital of america
merced
merced county sucks
it's the worst feel imagine
being real sweaty and you're on grass
and you get up you're like oh i'm so
itchy [ __ ] this grass but then put a
sweater on after and don't scratch it
like that oh
i gotta move i gotta scratch up inside
your brain oh that stinks it's so worth
it oh that stinks
truly terrible man truly like my lungs
sometimes on the inside i'm like just
yeah what do you do yeah yeah but it's
in your brains you're like that that's
why you see tweakers doing this [ __ ] all
the time
because their brains [ __ ] trip and oh
yeah that's nasty
what if it made you like like it was
like limitless the drug
no
it might be i've seen some structures
built by tweakers it's just it's just
adderall adderall is the same [ __ ] as
meth but it's like legal fancy adderall
yeah yeah i mean uh fancy method fancy
method what if they called a fancy myth
i mean fancy features
rebranded this fancy the generic name
don't ever give me some [ __ ] money
like that because i will start a
pharmaceutical brand
called a bunch of [ __ ] like eyes bleed
no more diarrhea though
it's a stupid [ __ ]
um
what are your next upcoming dates what
are you gonna be doing uh i'll go to
brea tomorrow uh
august 26th i think that is and then uh
bray on saturday as well
tucson
sunday and then um off for like uh until
september 19th i'll be in london
how how long are you working out the
hour do you know when you're gonna film
this well i'm gonna film it most likely
january
uh
2023 uh either here in la or in uh in
san francisco i haven't decided yet but
uh
these two cities haven't seen it ended
up doing like some theater in uh at the
ace hotel which like i don't know how
many seats and then uh masonic hall on
the 21st which is like 2200 seats
so
all that to say like
what's that for that illuminati yeah
yeah exactly uh tell us tech [ __ ] to
give me money uh invest yes uh that's
the that's the goal right now i i mean i
could put on tape now but
i don't think it's done yet i think
there's still a lot to figure out i
think like comedy's in a weird space
right now for the comedian it's like
what moves the needle for me
like it used to be the special it used
to be like you get a i think a huge
check it comes out on netflix the
special was everything but now it's like
the live dates move the needle and the
clips move the needle right you could be
getting way more on [ __ ] youtube than
you might off your special i think the
the goal from a
standard perspective is to just get out
there and get your [ __ ] seen by
whoever you may think like it and
whoever doesn't know they like it uh
because i haven't seen it yet
so whatever gets you that goal fastest
or best is uh
is best right like whatever like
whatever approach gets you that but in
the way you want it to have happen is
probably the best approach uh whether
that means
you know getting it on hbo or getting on
netflix or
clipping up what i did in uh last year
was clipped up the hour that i taped and
now it's on tick tock and on youtube and
[ __ ] and just like
serving as marketing for that
uh so what moves the needle i don't know
i think it's whatever gets you that goal
as my goal as a stand-up is get my [ __ ]
out there to as many people as can get
it out there
and can see it and then have them like
it
uh
and so tick-tock has proven to be that
right now that shit's blowing the [ __ ]
up tick-tock is gonna take over so many
things right now do you find that you
have a bunch of young ass like kid fans
on there though or is it not really like
that no i think it's a it's a huge tick
tock is very good at what it does
which is distribute content
as they thread the needle so well with
so many people
they're perfect at threading that
[ __ ] needle oh yeah but they're also
there that that needle is being threaded
like across a billion trillion people
that are on it
and so
like the show the shows are full of like
18 year olds and 20 year olds and 22
year olds and 20 like the whole range of
people i got i had 80 year old women at
my show before
uh multiple times like it's actually not
uncommon to see that and it's like every
race is represented what i found in
places that have bigger indian
populations i'll definitely have a lot
more new people represented but
at the same time like
like if i go to middle country you know
omaha nebraska
it's full i sold out omaha in march of
this year those markets are tough yeah
you know on like a wednesday i think
yeah
so it was like uh
uh
uh what's it called like the the reach
is so crazy of tick tock you know but
going back to what you said earlier like
about the special
like the special movement neon
i think the special has kind of lost its
luster a little bit uh
it
at least from an audience perspective
especially don't feel special anymore
yeah because there's so many of them and
they're so like uh
some of them very cook cutter mine look
fairly quick thank you channel looks
very cookie cutter like if you were to
see it it looks like a netflix special
which is two it's plus and minus it's
highly well produced but it's kind of
cookie cutter
and it's like and that's not to knock
the team at all it's like you know it's
all design input for me but
uh
uh i think that special kind of just
looks and feels not as special anymore
so expect it's hard for a special to
move the needle and also hard for a
special to be like
everyone being like yo you gotta see
this [ __ ] you know like i'm sure like
for what it's worth and kill him softly
and bigger and blacker and 100 some of
the big cat williams ones i mean i was
like
you gotta watch this school yeah
it was [ __ ] special so it's a lot
harder to make your special that ali
wong's most like the lat the first one
that made her like you know a household
name
you know what's it called a cobra cobra
cobra baby or something something like
that yeah and it was like that that was
of the specials i can remember the last
one that was like a big one a huge move
the needle kind of special
uh
you're not wrong or homecoming king for
hassan i think it did like crazy numbers
for him too uh and probably a few others
that i uh i'm missing but
uh the sp specialist doesn't feel as
special anymore and that's just a
function of fact that everyone has got
one you know as a fan of comedy you know
how much [ __ ] stand-up i watch
you're not wrong mm-hmm like when i hear
about myself it's good i'll watch it
tomorrow you know like i don't got to
watch it right [ __ ] now like it used
to be yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah chappelle
three in a row yeah [ __ ] it up not in
a bad way for because i'm stoked to
watch but it [ __ ] it up for the rhythm
i think it oversaturated the biggest
[ __ ] comic on the planet yeah yeah
too quick i think killing me softly was
that perfect
i got that [ __ ] on dvds too yeah yeah
yeah that was like the perfect sweet
spot for like comedy specials for me
when rogan had his uh the shiny happy
jihad one with his little kangol he had
on and [ __ ] i don't know that was like
probably 2009.
i don't know
i don't i'm not a game in terms of
specials at all like i know the ones i
know but outside of that i'm like i'm
[ __ ] talking about you [ __ ] the ed
murphy ones delirious [ __ ] of course of
course
what about comics today is there anybody
that you like to follow that you think
is like really funny today or doing it
right online or innovative
uh i mean besides the obvious i mean
obviously schultz was doing vinta akash
and they're all doing like fantastic
things on the marketing front and uh on
the comedy game yeah i mean they were
just talking about them earlier yeah
they i feel like they re he really
innovated especially through the clips i
mean when you're [ __ ] tall guys
you can do whatever you want yeah
yeah who's doing fun stuff
from a material perspective
i don't really know like i i've been
kind of blinders on for the last
forever like i don't really pay
attention to uh a lot of [ __ ] that's
been a couple years since i've been
actively looking at [ __ ] yeah i don't i
don't know what happened
i'm just so focused on myself i'm just
being very selfish with my time and my
energy and like i'm not a hyper focused
person so for me to
have that focus requires me to not think
about it like i you could easily spend
your time just watching other people's
questions all that stuff but it's like i
can't i don't have the time yeah i don't
have to totally feel you we don't listen
to a lot of other podcasts no i don't
have the time dude and it's like i don't
want to be
swayed
subconsciously by anything yeah exactly
yeah the worst thing happens you hear a
bit that you're doing you're like [ __ ]
and now there goes that i can't do that
[ __ ] anymore you know because if you're
blind to like [ __ ] i don't even know
who you are i've never even seen it
i go to sleep okay yeah because i think
about [ __ ] like this i make so much
content and people like yo it's already
done
i don't know you [ __ ] also why
am i talking to you the [ __ ] alone
it's like it's like
like some people will comment like this
guy did this similar joke and it's like
you think i know that i don't also [ __ ]
you i don't care
yeah it's almost impossible not to step
on ideas
it's impossible it's [ __ ] there's so
much [ __ ] in your pocket but that's why
like the hour that i have right now is
super about me and would be you'd be
hard-pressed yeah find anyone talking
about the same [ __ ] damn you're
impossible because it's all about you
it's all about me you know aziz once
told me only talk about what only you
can talk about i've taken the advice
from heart
did you see the video i think it was
lisa lampanellio's
no comedian no
i haven't no dis on lisa
she had just a full meltdown on a
heckler
it's a weird thing with hecklers like
dicks are you gonna stop the whole show
and make security take this [ __ ]
out are you gonna sit there and make fun
of him are you gonna act like you don't
see him or whatever like how do you deal
with if somebody's talking or being a
[ __ ] in the crowd
how do you do oh you ask me uh
well
it really depends on it's on a
case-by-case basis and i think i have a
pretty good read on uh
tone and what how people are behaving
and all that kind of stuff from
just being on stage for so long like i
can and just from being a human being
like i can tell someone's saying
something mean or try they want
attention or and how to like
disarm that person from what it is
they're trying to do you know those my
most recent viral clip on tic tac is me
shutting down a home responding to a
homophobic heckler
this guy i'm doing a joke but like it's
it's it's a throwaway joke within the
set so like by that i mean i mean like
by that i mean i know it's a bad joke
but in the context like you have to
understand the con the context is i'm
talking to a urologist and i'm trying to
make him laugh uh but with some hacky
[ __ ] so i say something hacky uh to try
to get in as i'm saying it you know some
guy yells out because it's gay and but
he didn't say it with a joke tone he
said it with a tone of like oh he's
trying to be like a dick a [ __ ]
uh and he actually is trying to use that
in a pejorative sense that's what i
heard
and that's what it sounded like because
that's what i think he was trying to do
so i flipped it on him was talking [ __ ]
to him and all these people in the
comments like
um that's that's a plant or no that's
not what he was saying
so on a it's on a case-by-case basis
that i'll evaluate but you know other
times it's someone yelling [ __ ] out and
i'm just like you're just trying to help
but you're not doing a good job at it
you know
which is
identical situation but if you you can
hear someone trying to help versus some
trying to be rude hey what's up man hey
what's up man it's like oh
it's all time chill out it's all tone so
if lisa lampanelli went off on somebody
i'm sure it was
either someone who'd been heckling the
whole time and and knew what they were
doing being antagonistic and she was
like alright that's the [ __ ] end-all
be-all
or
it was the end of her rope uh and it
didn't matter what was going on and and
this person had no idea what the [ __ ]
they were doing uh they just thought
they were trying to be funny and lisa
was like you don't [ __ ] and it was like
they probably been like 14 other
hecklers before that heckler that yeah
went on in like that context you know
it's really just case by case if someone
says some goofy [ __ ] i can
and then at the end of the day the
trigger's always there it's like get him
a water and that's like cold for get
them to [ __ ] out you know oh i like that
oh that's just the phrase yeah yeah
whatever the phrase is that you have i
like that because it is awkward
she was like security like really stop
the show like this isn't funny anymore i
like that i pull some jeans and [ __ ]
walk out
remember that [ __ ] you remember when
someone heckled gene simmons no he
[ __ ] got out went into the crowd
stood over the man the guy [ __ ]
simmons and then he walked back on stage
all old as [ __ ] that's what happened
that's what happened yeah i mean there's
definitely been uh uh
conversations with staff being like the
staff is always at most clubs is always
like so if someone heckles you like how
do you want to handle that i'm like
you'll know like i'll be like you'll
know you'll know you can tell you know
it's like if something's crazy they'll
approach like or like you i can see them
coming
and then it's gotten to that point for
you i mean no that's just a that that's
the thing that happens like if someone's
attacking from you and i've engaged like
security will naturally kind of focus
their attention to that like just pay
attention what's going on just in case i
say the code words
and uh did you see that wild video of
mike tyson where the dude was doing
stand-up in front of him no what
it was like a small little venue like
the size of this room and there's like a
dude doing stand-up or some [ __ ] and
like the host asks him to get off stage
tyson's just sitting there just right in
front of him and the the dude asked him
like to get off stage or some [ __ ] the
dude pulls a gun out oh yeah
like i don't see that i don't know
what's up
you got it he's like he's got it right
he's like
he like gave him dude
at the end he hugged him and he
apologized mike tyson put his gun away
but mike tyson's like this with the
pistol in his eyes okay yeah it's like
yo you're not [ __ ] around
you can't fight him yeah he'll bite you
you don't care about a gun
it's mike tyson
he's the calmest
craziest pothead in the world man he
just cracked a smile on that gun he did
he did he went
what are you gonna do
oh [ __ ] no but mike tyson was getting a
single show like he was one guy in a
crowd and he was comedian on stage this
guy rushes in he's like i love you i
love you and then he pulls the gun out
[ __ ] you he's talking [ __ ] because
they're throwing them out uh-huh it's a
very weird time it's a weird moment yeah
i got to see this yeah we'll bring it up
we're moving our studio into the same
room with this he's about to be our set
neighbor oh really that's crazy because
it's us matt barnes and this show we're
going to be like on the roster for this
agency i gotta come bro i want to meet
that matt barnes
that [ __ ] is big as [ __ ] yeah i
know i know that he's a monster um
but i i told marty i'm like i'm excited
and i'm mad nervous
yeah i'm
wondering what's gonna happen you think
you smoke weed yeah oh no no i i
guarantee i'm gonna give him a run for
his [ __ ] money like you're
trying to smoke a pound mike tyson
yeah oh for sure yeah mike tyson they
said smokes forty thousand dollars worth
of weed a month yeah i heard that too
that must be expensive and he's got his
own strain so yeah like
yeah though you know me yeah yeah
pretty sure i'm like yo you're trying to
smoke eight grams of hash
i win
i could beat you at something that's
good it's not like you say i knocked you
out of the car i got it i could see you
and mike sitting there playing [ __ ]
knockouts yeah like
shinobi it's so epic yeah yeah oh man i
can't wait also wait hold on you were
the kid with a good grit and [ __ ]
you had video games of course yeah i had
to ask what was your [ __ ] game as a
kid
golden eye oh you were the double oh
yeah yeah yeah i love the intro
that was my [ __ ] golden eye was what i
played sucked at it i was a monster so i
just [ __ ] love playing with my
cousins and i we play all the time just
a game slept on people don't bring that
up with [ __ ] it's true
you're right it's not brought up enough
like metal gear too and my homies were
all about metal gear
i just played shinobi i don't know what
shinobi is sega uh the little uh ninja
that throws stars it's just the side
view and he just walked it was wacko
it was a wacky play sonic on sega of
course that was everybody but like
goldeneye was uh the family game we
would for we had four controllers would
be like all of us in rotation just like
all right oh that's hard it was the best
i would always be the second scientist
you're always the scientist second
scientist she's second she could blend
into the walls better so i feel like oh
you played this yeah yeah yeah
you play it for real depending on the
levels like you could uh
play it a couple weeks ago i went to the
call of duty world series what is that i
called you to the world championship
uh-huh that makes more sense yeah world
championship
bro have you ever been to esports
anything no i've never seen a esports
tournament that sounds dope i walked in
and there was nobody else i'm like this
is going to be whack it's at a coliseum
like there's nobody outside there's one
security guard
but i forgot it's like a bunch of nerd
dudes yeah yeah so no one's like getting
shitfaced and fighting and asking where
you're from with rags on right so i walk
in and it's [ __ ] packed of course
stadium
a stage some desks
dudes playing with gigantic screens
and a [ __ ] announcer guys up top with
the cameras you saw my live stream i
went in crazy there was lines of people
wait like 100 people waiting for some
little guy
signing the controller with a j with a
full like ufc kid on yeah yeah but it's
all like
something gaming yeah the fighter the
avenger like
people were signing up buying jerseys
like it was a basketball game they're
probably making millions of dollars 100
yeah yeah the the prize was i think it
was two mil
did they play like forever did the game
take for [ __ ] ever no it's just a
call of duty game i don't know how long
it's like a [ __ ] 10 minutes man
that's all it was but it's tournament
style you know it's like [ __ ] cobra
kai [ __ ] [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] but for video games is
it was it team or was it individuals
yeah so optic gaming we've had a hex
optic uh he's the owner of it and he's
like
i don't know about video games that much
but i so i went and
you know people have their jerseys
they're doing chants in the [ __ ]
crowd i gotta go yo the coolest thing i
ever saw i'm trying to go watch a mario
one like this cities have teams he said
he's sold la something new york he sold
his team to the owner of the texas
rangers yeah and then he's like i didn't
like how they were handling the brand so
i bought it back from them and i own it
again that's interesting i wonder how
much teams cost
they paid 100 mil 100 million dollars
for their team that's [ __ ] crazy you
ever heard of the faze clan guys no
there's a people called faze clan i know
they're video game guys i don't know
about them i don't watch video games or
youtube i just watch fights
they just sold their [ __ ] team
there's 10 people on their team just
give me one guess how much you think
they sold their video game
homies clan name for
10 million
billion dollars but a billion would have
bee
they've all got 100 million for each
sports team
he's got 100 all 10 guys damn
oh that's how they did it god damn they
own ten percent oh
because eric's friends were one of those
one of them and he's like bro he really
told me they gave me a hundred million
[ __ ] dollars because they paid us a
billion and you continue to play but now
yeah you probably still have a
percentage and you just you're the face
but you're bought out you're done
go [ __ ] live it up man you're playing
video games well 100 million dollars
yeah see i [ __ ] up man see i [ __ ] up
golden eye man bring back gold tonight
man oh man that's damn [ __ ] that's
athlete money man yeah that's right
it's like that's russell west you got 10
brett favre's out here [ __ ]
y'all so you owning do you watch sports
a little bit okay yeah yeah do you watch
football not as much as i should uh okay
okay what team if you had to pick a
teacher but that's only because you're
going to new york okay
but basketball kobe fan
lakers uh
sad last year but obviously uh hopefully
this year will be a uh interesting i
want to see what happens off season but
can you make any sense out of me i
always thought it was so weird how you
got the jets and the giants in the same
stadium right uh-huh ones from one's the
new jersey jets one though
jets yeah new jersey jets new york
giants right no no new york new york
they're both new york teams it was the
new jersey jets though right maybe like
the 60s yeah i don't know when it was
just that [ __ ] was always weird to me
that they were like in the wrong state
is that not weird oh
that they don't play in new york at all
like they should be in long island kind
of yeah like they're in [ __ ] new
jersey
i'm sure there's an answer to that
question but now the [ __ ] niners
playing santa clarita so they're not
even in the frisco no more [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
you should go to a laker game out here i
want to go man my timing is never
intersected but actually
no i think about it
i'm gonna i might be here in november
uh so maybe i'll swing by if i if the
schedule lines up i'll do electrical
games i did one we got the box thing
because my friend
i just leave at that we had the box
thing
and uh it was awesome i'm afraid of
heights it was just terrible for me but
it was cool to see [ __ ] like
that yeah
i guarantee you have a great experience
guys i i would i've been a lot of knicks
games uh in nets games uh nick's game is
like i've been very close because chain
i would go time to time and he gets like
insane seats from the garden new york
yeah
uh uh
there's nothing i mean the box is great
but there's nothing like being on like
in the actual court and just having a
great time like but i've been so spoiled
i'm like i can't go to section 200 ever
again oh you're fine it's over
i know exactly how you feel when you see
when you see the
the
guys on in real life like that's the
biggest person i've ever seen in my
entire life
that's just such a big person you always
feel like i can handle myself and you
see a [ __ ] like
you could do oh you could break my neck
probably yeah yeah i've only met a few
people that made me feel like scared
like do you murder my chiropractor i
told you
[ __ ] lou ferrigno chiropractor he's
the biggest man ever as he's cracking my
back i was like dude
you could kill me yeah i didn't realize
you could fold me like ball over from
[ __ ] bruce lee and just snap my body
in half
i [ __ ] with that [ __ ] it scares the hell
out of me
like yo if i was in prison i'd have to
fight you i'd die no you'd be [ __ ] i
mean that's that's
like you literally literally and [ __ ]
figuratively
but when you're uh
that like that
experience is like second to none like
being up close but so i would love to go
later game when i'm here i just don't
know when
if the timing works out in november if
they're going to be here now i'm just
thinking that's what that trainer felt
like when peyton manning was starting to
[ __ ]
you could keep oh
i forgot about this marty i'll use the
scarred peyton manning for me bro that's
my first callback
cause you never remember what the [ __ ]
we're talking about we have a segment
called what the [ __ ] was i talking about
nice that's called every segment of the
show yeah okay let's do one last thing
before we uh wrap this up can we do who
were you in the 90s for sure thank you
while i'm pulling that up i was
wondering do you do you dabble with any
sort of shrooms or anything like that
yeah you have shrooms
i think i do in the back room actually
uh yeah capsules i love i love shrimps
uh
uh
i haven't had a full ego death trip yet
so i didn't know what that was but when
i take shoes i eat seven i ate seven
grams at that time me and my wife that's
a lot it's a lot but i do it in the dark
no i'm in the pitch black no no music
because i've done shrooms a lot but it's
always like hanging out yeah i wanted to
experience something else best thing i
ever did in my life oh really it's
[ __ ] scary but i was like above my
head it's a long story i was like seeing
my body flying around talking about
people people like you experience this
and ego this like what the [ __ ] you're
talking about yeah but for weeks after i
was just
dwelling on it like you know when you
watch a crazy ass thing like damn i
can't stop thinking about that
[ __ ] weeks yeah yeah so i have
experienced whatever that is it's
[ __ ] scary i've never done that but
it seems like something i would like to
do at some point in my life it's fun you
ever [ __ ] with other psychedelics
lsd i've done oh okay
uh
twice i think i did it how'd you like
that compared to shrooms it's kind of
very very similar uh the first time i
did i kind of [ __ ] it for myself
because i also smoked and you're not
supposed to do that unless you want to
like go into like hyperdrive and like
[ __ ] your brain up in terms of like the
thoughts you're thinking all that uh and
so i was like catatonic and like don't
talk to me anybody for like a while and
then i'll come back at it and then go
back into it kind of thing uh it was too
intense but the second time i did i was
like oh this [ __ ] is fire it's fun it's
like it's just like shrooms
uh uh i heard it feels uh more
controllable
yes that's what it felt like too because
you can it's a
it's a what's it called
made drug like so yeah
yeah you're not a man-made exact i kind
of think of that but
it's constructed by some people what's
the word you know constructed man
so it's easier to dose
i mean i've heard so many good things
about it the only reason was my aunt
used to do remember the 90s when [ __ ]
hippies came back for some reason my
aunt was one of those people and her
friend
her friend
they used to ask all the time might go
over her house swim and then one day she
was just weird and i found out later she
went schizophrenic after a bad [ __ ]
acid trip yeah that's crazy it scarred
me forever yeah yeah it's a good reason
to not do it i just do mushrooms yeah
yeah do you ever do you ever tried dmt
no i haven't either never done it me
neither there's a there's a good
brand of shrooms called hero bars
it's like uh
like a 10 grand bar made out of
chocolate bar like a wonka bar yeah but
it's like uh they have like perfect
markings so like this is like one for
this five for this 10
but like i've had other bars like that
before like the boom bar is good but the
hero bar is like
oh you don't just dabble you like true
yeah like you know the [ __ ] name yeah
we we don't get a lot of people that
[ __ ] with mushrooms
especially from new york
i don't know yeah
it was just like the hero bars the first
time i had it was in san francisco
because our friend gave it to us uh
and i was at this
like house party kind of and like i gave
it out to everybody and everyone was
like
these are amazing
i'm like yeah they are [ __ ] fantastic
my mom's been on shrooms for like eight
months
every time she had any more shrooms like
[ __ ] mom
she's going hard dude she's just eating
mushrooms all the time that's awesome
i know i've been so busy man i don't
have enough time because i like i said i
go [ __ ] hard i don't have enough time
to sit for eight hours yeah and not look
at business [ __ ] and like again no more
routine with it do you like to be alone
and or do you like i do it socially i'm
not like again like i haven't done like
a crazy trip or anything like that yeah
the microdose is fun i did it recently
like a
a little more than a micro but not
necessarily like anything
hyper perceptible
does not feel
different yeah yeah like slightly
elevated
maybe some like movement on the walls
like and leaves and [ __ ] but beyond that
like nothing crazy see that's what i
need to get into more like just
a little bit because i did it one time
i did like a gram and a half and it was
so fun it's nice it's like a buzz it was
like a buzz and then i did too much on
here one day when during an episode and
i had to [ __ ] cut the episode off it
was i was done wall started swimming all
started swimming on me i couldn't like i
kept forgetting like we're oh we're
filming yeah yeah no i i don't do that
that often uh i haven't done that uh
it's usually just like a social amount
uh going out like [ __ ] around talking
to people [ __ ] homie makes uh
psilocybin pens who does like my homie
makes psilocybin vape pens
so like a couple of hitches you know
he's like usually six or seven hits i'm
starting to trip a little bit that's
crazy his dmt ones that sounds sick that
sounds amazing yeah yeah that sounds
dangerous yeah he left him in my house
one time for a couple weeks when he went
out of town like yo put that [ __ ] away
in a [ __ ] box in my closet because
they will get smoked to here yeah
somebody's going to ruin their day yeah
yeah could you ask me what a tnt fit at
my house and you just hate that mushroom
flavor
to be done yeah whole day's gone i don't
know what gmt does um it's just
it's so hard to explain and if i haven't
done it i don't really feel like i can
even explain it yeah i don't know let's
just say mushrooms times a thousand oh
okay yeah i'm good yeah yeah i'm good
you ever tried salvia no okay don't
you're fine yeah yeah it's trash um all
right hold on real quick let's do this
who are you in the 90s this is a little
segment we do okay just want to get the
feel of uh who's here all right and
you're very blunt
exactly hey yo
exactly marty that was a good time i
guess
you just started with a tongue roll what
the [ __ ] are you ready yeah who are you
in the 90s um i'm just going to ask you
a question you just pick in between
that's it okay v and remember this is
you as you said you're born in 86 yeah
so you're in the night you're like
you're like a eight-year-old kid 10
maybe 12. you know what i mean so in
that state vh1 or mtv mtv quick as hell
that was the quickest answer ever yeah
easily of course for sure each one
[ __ ] sucked besides behind the music
hard one adam sandler or jim carrey
movies
jim carrey i think uh i'm trying to
think but again like
i don't remember when
a water boy came out 96 okay so then
adam sandler wait when did liar liar
come up 96. okay so both
[Laughter]
97.
but still uh like like i saw
if i had to choose who took the race it
was jim carrey because i stayed watching
more of his movies uh i followed him
slightly more than i followed adam but i
also watched a lot of adams movies too
like all the drama stuff that they both
tried to do uh so i think it's i think
it's fairly neck and neck right now i
played ball with sandler so
uh name drop what up adam
uh
because we worked on a movie together i
was on set with rock like doing uh
punch-up with him and it was the movie
they did together so uh i met adam and
got to know him a little bit and so yeah
his all-time favorite person adam's the
best nicest guy in the world yeah he's a
hooper too right he's balls
yeah no i've been watching he's [ __ ]
fairly good he's like tank of a man yeah
no i stopped uh playing soccer and went
to
football because of the water boy uh-huh
it's like turning point in my life
absolutely incredible yeah it was
[ __ ] wild but i get it jim carrey
movies it's like the mask the dancing
with the cops
it doesn't get more fun than that [ __ ]
as a kid like yo
i had the mask on vhs yeah i still do
yeah yeah
phase yes i just bought a
a sculpture of it like a toy that moves
stanley ipkis that [ __ ] is
detailed it's got wrinkles on his face
and it comes with milo with the mask on
that's fantastic it's hard as hell yeah
yeah yeah um all right so jim carrey
wins on this one
it's hard because that's my favorite
it's a tie it's a tie it's just a test
tie it's the first tie and who were you
in the 90s history yeah i think it is
yeah yeah tupac or biggie smalls biggie
okay quick again yeah is it because he's
from new york you just like the music
better music was better than me okay
that's not to say i was not [ __ ] with
tupac of course
neck and neck but just one's a little
higher yeah when you're in middle school
did you have like all eyes on me life
after death were you listening to that
[ __ ] i had i had uh life i had biggie's
album uh i think we might have had
tupac's album too my cousin and i would
share it but
uh uh it was biggie was more accessible
to us
uh like i think i just got the biggie
album before that and it was also more
on mtv i think biggie was more on mtv at
the time i don't know did they let you
listen to [ __ ] like that or not so much
at some point became kind of
uncontrollable what i was doing with
music and stuff you know it was like
they're gonna they're not paying
attention constantly so they didn't like
that we would listen to it but at some
point you and your cousins yeah did you
have any brother sisters i had a younger
sister oh okay okay i have a younger
sister way younger four years so adults
a generation yeah that's that's a whole
high school year yeah yeah the
generation is a high school
uh chunk i think like five years yeah
whole is it yeah i think so oh well damn
yeah that's a generation apart
so yeah
all right so big smiles mm-hmm
although it changes holds a deer place
in my heart it's by you know it's hard
yeah yeah it's another two pi it's
another adam sandler jim carrey it's
hard that's why we do this [ __ ] i just
make [ __ ] thing like but do i
um so here we go next
this one's always i feel like we gotta
change this one up we know what no we're
all kids full house or family matters as
a kid
whoa family matters family matters nope
steve was too funny yeah yeah for sure i
mean we watched both obviously a lot but
family matters takes the cake it's like
my parents would watch family matters
not full houses yeah not a full house
family matters like this urkel kid yeah
crazy there was no [ __ ] hercules yeah
no but
i gotta say i [ __ ] [ __ ] with full
house heavy uncle jesse you know joey
man
they were funny as hell is kids man the
funniest line ever i remember is when uh
joey gladstone walked in the kitchen and
danny tanner's got the he's like got the
soap going on his hand and then joey
gladstone goes that's it folks he's
officially started washing the soap
[ __ ] bombs
that's [ __ ] great
i better you go back you probably
there's a lot of jokes we missed there's
so many jokes yeah there's so many jokes
that they make a hundred percent um yeah
but for me i gotta go family matters
it's one of my favorite shows ever it's
great i loved it
real quick uh one time i'm getting high
just smoking weed literally just just
smoking a joint my friend facetimes like
what's up man because hey i'm with
somebody you're gonna want to meet me
and go what are you talking about and he
goes and goes what's up man eddie
winslow go shut the [ __ ] up that's on my
balcony i'm talking to eddie winslow
about the [ __ ] my favorite episodes
for like 10 minutes it was
hold it for you you met urkel too right
yeah i was at a wee party i turned
around like oh it's stuff on her kill is
he good was he cool [ __ ] cool
stuff on her kill
that's [ __ ] awesome like yo you made
my day i'm gonna leave the party now i
know george costanza style i'm out of
here bro
yeah
julia white
it's a little white's type yeah all
right here we go
pulp fiction or forrest gump
forrest gump
[ __ ] yeah because i was too young to
appreciate what the [ __ ] pulp fiction
was oh i'm 13. i'm
i'm 10 years old in 1996. you know
that's a good point that's a good point
but my mom was terrible i watched it at
five uh-huh i was watching all this [ __ ]
it was probably sick as a [ __ ] you know
when you're [ __ ] like oh my god but
you had no idea what's going on i didn't
get i won't go too into detail you know
you two [ __ ] hate this but i didn't
get a lot of the things basement scene
yeah i'm like what
the spider caught a fly yeah i didn't
understand why is he got a full suit and
he was in a box yeah
where's my mom at like i don't know
what's happening mom what's the red ball
in his mouth mean
dude for real that was it uh uh natural
killers she told me not to watch and it
that kind of scared me yeah natural
kills would [ __ ] anybody yeah when
there's a hot dog the pharmacist that
scared the [ __ ] yeah you there's but so
far and all forrest gump is also just on
all the time you know like once it came
out like i think it was a year or two
later that went into syndication it was
just on television she's such a good
[ __ ] family it's such a good move
but yeah it's just a easily digestible
you watch it like over and over like man
this is so good it was my uh
maybe bleep out bat yeah stop it get in
trouble again sorry here we go you ready
it or chucky and i'm talking about it
with with tim curry do you ever watch
that i'm gonna say neither but only
because i i don't think we want i think
i probably watched it and i'll probably
also watch chucky but i was of the age
to be like
this is corny as hell oh you weren't
that kid i was [ __ ]
i'm not a real phobia but like clowns
freak me out i don't like oh they do but
that's probably from the movie it but
you should watch it as an adult it's not
like that scary tim curry's just a great
[ __ ] actor oh okay he's so funny at
the same time in two seconds like you
scared the [ __ ] out of me yeah even now
mm-hmm but chucky i i had a fear of
dolls as a kid got it okay and i mean
chuck i mean i'll both of them like just
just [ __ ] hit him or something you
know like as a kid like that's who i was
in the 90s
who i was just [ __ ] hit him just hit
the [ __ ] cops
take his head off
all right here we go i still scared me
he was killing grown adults
this [ __ ] doll that's what scared the
[ __ ] out of me here we go
mario or donkey kong mario good [ __ ]
yeah you only had one donkey kong ever
yeah i never really played donkey kong i
didn't [ __ ] with it jumping over barrels
i'm switching that to luigi or some [ __ ]
no we can't do something we gotta it's
gotta be
earlier it was mario but then sonic was
just such a better entertainment system
like the graphics were better
it was for me i could never do the spin
out and go because i was a little kid
and my parents were just on drugs like
you know who's going to show me the
buttons so i'm just tapping and he i can
never get fully around until i was like
four or five
mr robot here we go here we go
mcdonald's are burger king oh burger
king as a kid
you're the first burger king ever
because we didn't we didn't eat a lot of
beef grown up i've had chicken
sandwiches chicken sandwiches a long one
yep [ __ ]
yes it was the best so it was [ __ ]
bomb and it was uh i think i had beef
like if i was gonna have beef it would
be at burger king and i would have a uh
i had the whopper a few times
but the chicken like by then we were
ingrained to go to burger king
and everything about the burger king was
just better like chicken i like the
chicken sandwich better
and uh
target or walmart same [ __ ] uh yeah
they're okay yeah but it's just cleaner
everyone's taking target in that i think
question yeah
burger king is target to me it's like oh
it's better yeah it's almost the same
it's the same thing but just slightly
better it's better yeah sweet uh no
one's like i can't wait to spend my day
at walmart exactly let's go target get
some [ __ ] real quick might get a desk
there's something odd going on about
target for sure like they've definitely
figured out
something about it's like weird asmr
[ __ ] they got going on so they would
like because
my wife is like well go i love targeting
just like looking at every girl i know
everyone loves talk and then like my
cousin
he's like i sometimes just go talking
and just like browse [ __ ]
like i wish i had the time to go do some
browsing i'm just like that's tight he's
like i'm like and then he's like me too
bro i'm like
our cousin-in-law like i was like
well something's going on they're
pumping some [ __ ] in the air at target
where it's like there's something's
going on in target but burger king
probably doing the same [ __ ] uh burger
king is just and i like the fries better
too burgundy fries is the [ __ ] yeah
long-ass chicken sandwich i play a fun
game in every store which is see how
high you can get and then go in and see
how quickly you can find this obscure
[ __ ] well that's just supposed to ask
[ __ ] out at target yeah no any story
marty marty uh has three children uh-huh
so marty does not get high all the time
oh so when he
can't marty before he walked he goes
last night i was in the shower i hit two
of the pens almost [ __ ] passed down
set the fire alarms off
are the kids with the sitters or
something
no because they're downstairs he's up in
his bathroom oh god i gotta sneak my
[ __ ] heads i did a double blinker
yesterday not even thinking it was just
casual i'm just like
two of them double blinker
almost [ __ ] died
double blinker what is that once you hit
it for so long it'll turn off and it
starts blinking oh that's it's just a
ridiculous ass yeah thing oh god it's
just all vapings it'll turn off at a
certain point yeah it's just a thing um
[ __ ] telemundo that's all i'll say i did
a thing for them about blinkers and how
kids shouldn't smoke unregulated cards
and i don't speak spanish
and these fools mutilated me and had me
think i was a drug dealer telling kids
they should go smoke [ __ ] black i
chopped it up they chopped my words up
to make it and they only used me coffee
it was a psa it was a [ __ ] piece on
tv with me i shot it like a commercial
oh that's so it was so it was like
propaganda and i called the [ __ ] after
and text her and
i was so obsessed with you sue them
no i don't give a [ __ ] that was just me
that was the [ __ ] out of it i agreed to
it they just chopped up my words like a
[ __ ] ransom note they used your just
likeness they did they did [ __ ]
[ __ ] my grandma saw it [ __ ]
here we go michael jackson or michael
jordan jordan yeah
of course
uh although not to sleep on i was big
michael jackson fan this is like all
very close seconds uh uh but jordan i
wasn't wearing michael jackson's shoes
you know that's a true statement it was
just like i also wasn't singing [ __ ]
basketball movies yeah the bus i don't
want to brag but michael jackson died on
my birthday oh my god marty so delia
don't wanna jesus christ
i don't wanna brag you know influential
people have been dead on my birthday
before it's probably worse
right every year you live is because one
of them died
[Music]
and that's why you can date black dudes
way older than you oh [ __ ] rock the boat
marty
rocked the boat marty i had like a pants
on the other day all right
no barriers in the world considers cargo
pants just to leave those are leah pants
are they camouflage
no they're just khaki carter pants they
were kind of baggy i'm like yeah oh she
had leah she had those in the um romeo's
die video i think right yeah i don't
remember i just remember
when you said that i'm like those are
really apparently yeah she was she was
like yes
all day i was in new york i'm like yo
i'm about to rock these aaliyah pants i
should get some malia pants you should
brother tight i'm gonna get some cargos
now last one
we gotta change this one it's hard
it's light-skinned rabbit nesquik
remember the nesquik little rabbit yeah
i don't remember that at all
or
[Laughter]
it's the other one
lights came with rabbit on that do you
remember nesquik the little rabbit on
the nesquik oh yes
i'm like white skinned a little light
skinned rabbit wasn't it white like why
no he was like slightly brown and he was
dark a little bit and he had white on
his chest oh okay okay
or cleaning the kale orange soda that's
what we need to start changing it too oh
yeah so we're going to go keen and kill
orange soda i guess yeah keenan kel
owner soda for whatever brand he was
chugging that's the orange show that one
yeah we need to know that brand it was
just orange it just said orange
what's the question though is which
you know when you're a little kid like
yo sonny d full remember the commercials
oh oh would you rather would you what
are you drinking what are you as a kid
going you know i drink [ __ ] yuhu
every day i drink that i just wanna get
what were you as a kid she's like i was
flipping on my collar and [ __ ] i was
saying i would start i would start every
morning with more oval team please
she really took over i love the oval
team
thank you christmas stories
i mean i haven't had any in a long time
yeah it's just like off-brand chocolate
milk no but it's so chocolatey i think
so but i don't know it's like the
nutella of a powdered drink but it's so
good
i kind of want to try this it's so good
i just know it from christmas and it's
like
a it's got a different texture than um
uh nesquik okay so nesquik is like super
powdery it was oval things a little
grainier and so like when it's at the
bottom of the glass it is chocolate milk
i think uh at the bottom of the glass
you get like the little uh chunks yeah
broken down cookies yeah it's [ __ ]
bang damn i've been [ __ ] um
just trying to tell it recently too yeah
i'm [ __ ] up heavy well yeah well
nutella wasn't it's like more like an
adult food almost yeah yeah
i mean yeah but it's just chocolate yeah
sauce isn't it i guess like i guess when
i was like i guess like
does that mean i thought that was a
[ __ ] soundboard [ __ ]
[Music]
you feel healthier giving your kid
nutella than just straight chocolate in
my mind it's like made out of almonds or
some [ __ ] it's [ __ ] hazelnut and yeah
hazelnut yeah corn syrup that's what
that [ __ ] is it's poison okay all right
well
sorry about that
it's high fructose corn syrup it's
poison
[Laughter]
don't have commercial sweets
or any yes
it's just
hey man i'm trying i'm trying to out
here live like sean shirk remember ufc
sean sure because i only eat for fuel
he's the buffest man ever he only ate to
replenish his body like a video game
i don't know about that life no that
sounds sounds like dooky man i i try to
live like that you know just like uh
very early on like man it's just food
just who cares but then i got into food
a little bit here and there i'm like no
you can there's such a
good
value to be derived from eating like
really what nice good food like eating
at a fancy restaurant or like well not
even fancy restaurants just a place
there's no no until recently was that
the food quality difference i had no
idea oh yeah it's huge it's like oh this
is what pasta's supposed to be
right you know this is what i'm supposed
to do new york is the best food i ever
had my life new york cause i couldn't i
told you i'm like yo what the [ __ ] is
ellie doing out here where did you eat
uh place
uh [ __ ] it's called like glass candy or
some [ __ ] okay dirt candy dirt candy
vegetarian food
it's good
yeah yeah yeah it was cranberry it was
like art yeah yeah i'm like oh
are you vegan or vegetarian yeah vegan
yeah oh okay but um did you go to
avant-garde
i don't know i went to some place i was
just high the whole time you know my
wife's just picked i'm like we're going
to these places we had it all planned
out so i don't know what the place was
called we just ubered there uber avant
garden is like this fantastic vegan spot
in the
uh what's it called east village if
you're it was in east village if your
wife was planning it was fancy vegan
[ __ ] then yeah then it was you probably
went there probably did there was like
four spots it's like the no no top rated
spots we just went to all yeah yeah i
mean dark candy's good i'm a garden
blows it out of the water uh i don't
know the other two but i know those two
yeah it was cool man uh uh i liked it
yeah it was dope man hella fans out
there [ __ ] new york new york's tight
time square is not that [ __ ] tight at
all no time sucks
it was like going to the grove but in
new york
except this fool's like just asleep
outside yeah time square was trash yeah
it was whack lieutenant dan all those
[ __ ] and they made it look so
much cooler bro no no foreskill made
everything a little better
all right
i'm sorry that's what i'm thinking right
now um that's literally hit throughout
here in the 90s i've got to change that
last one that orange orange soda milk
okay uh we got to go harder cause i feel
like not enough people know who the
light skin rabbit is from that's quick
okay fair point i do though but when
they do know it's a connection like yeah
i know the lightsaber rabbit which
rabbit did you care more about the light
skin rabbit on the next nest label or
trix rabbit
honestly i feel played for the trixx
rabbit song i feel sympathy for him he
got played he's in the box
he's [ __ ] privileged as children just
starving a rabbit to death essentially
for years on tv there you go
that's uh someone did a sketch about
that i think it was like uh uh
jermaine jermaine fowler had a joke
about it like
anyone else feel bad about that rabbit
these bad silly ass kiss [ __ ] that
rabbit man
i think that's a germain joke how i feel
about you yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
just starving
see you can never do it like somebody
already talked about it so just [ __ ]
talk about it yeah never it's never
ending for sure i love it
um so real quick your next one's in la
brea
brea not la brea i think libra is a la
town right this is is it the same place
no no okay no right it's in brazil
yeah yeah yeah uh like 45 minutes east
of
here i think
southeast uh
at the brea improv this weekend august
26th 27th tucson on august 28th london
september 19th i don't get a lot of
london people yell the uk fans for some
reason london september 19th uh and then
it's the first time out of the country
performing no i've done canada a whole
bunch oh uh but uh it's my first time in
london i've talked a lot of [ __ ] about
england so it's gonna be fun talk [ __ ]
you'll have something there uh well i
don't appreciate it [ __ ] you yeah i
can't wait uh actually and then uh
and then i'm off for another two weeks
and then i'm back
stateside going to st louis detroit
grand rapids
madison wisconsin san diego
uh when am i after san diego i don't
remember the fact that you remembered
all those is [ __ ] wild dc
november 5th at the warner theater
come everybody see all this at what's
your website findingnemesh.com finding
nimesh.com
right there uh social medias finding
nemesh at finding nemesh on everything
on everything yes sir all right um i
just wanted to make sure we got that out
of the way also for everyone out there
because i know a lot of [ __ ] on
the internet
just go
my suggestions just go on this full
stick talk and just give yourself about
15 minutes
and have fun
that's how you started going up that's
how i found you that's why like i said
with a booking agent totally go [ __ ]
run it like yes you've never said that
this is i know i noticed that yeah run
that [ __ ] because i know
i've never obviously never met i've seen
what i've seen i'm ready to you know i
mean like thank you as a fan i'm ready
to ready to watch so i hope you guys can
go out there and watch this is more of a
i just want to get to know people and
you know say someone's right here like
i've never seen you stand up this guy
was nice he was cool he's chill and go
watch like
that's a new fan man as long as there's
one new [ __ ] watching your [ __ ]
and going hey i like it that's all that
matters that's all you need that's all
you need thank you ma'am no appreciate
you cheers miller time mailer time
appreciate you guys marty
thank you guys this was fun i love
having new yorkers on the show i love
having new yakas salute appreciate you
guys i'm short so thank you thank you
[ __ ] people
it's okay
i'm going to grow soon guys thank you so
much for being here this has been the
dopes usual podcast is here to talk
about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between have a dope as day
i am pretty [ __ ] high off those two
joints
[Music]